we delivered justice to bin laden a
decade ago
and we've stayed in afghanistan for a
decade since
it's time to end america's longest war
it's time for american troops to come
home
president biden announcing the
withdrawal of all u.s
troops from afghanistan by september
11th
the move causing fierce bipartisan
backlash
and claims it could cause another 911.
okay uh i'm going to start with you dana
you know
uh when biden said that what happened on
9 11
was terrible but that was 20 years ago
and this is now it doesn't explain why
we're there now
is it really that simple oh i think
nothing about this is simple i think it
is exceedingly complex
with a ton of nuance and you know i
would say a couple of things one
one i think that the sacrifices that
have been made by so many
men and women in uniform and in our
intelligence services and in our
diplomatic corps
have not been for nothing um i just want
to remind everybody that we didn't start
this war
this war came to us and then we had a
choice of
how do you want to fight it in the last
several years
um thanks and really do mostly to
president trump the posture is very
different
we do not have a hundred thousand troops
in afghanistan we have fewer than five
thousand troops in afghanistan right now
they are doing counter intelligence they
are doing some training
they are also the eyes and ears on the
ground for the fact that the iranians
for example
are arming uh al qaeda which is
re-establishing itself
in afghanistan so um
look this this decision i'm sure will
come as a comfort to the
families of the servicemen and women
that have served many of whom signed up
right after 9 11.
from a communication standpoint i cannot
for the life of me understand
the decision to say we are going to
leave on 9 11.
and handing a propaganda tool to the
taliban they are obviously
no matter what they're going to say haha
we expelled the infidels
but this war came to our shores and we
can decide how to
fight it and how to end it the other
thing i would say is this
the administration again this could be a
good plan
secretary pompeo today said a lot of
this is going to be in the execution
i would ask this if we are going to do
this then will we
accept the people from afghanistan like
we did in vietnam the vietnamese
refugees who came here
those who the school teachers the
interpreters the helicopter pilots
that were on our side and how the
targets now are on their back
so we have to do the right thing in the
leaving
i mean god speed to us all all right
let's take a listen to what lindsey
graham said today and
we're going to go to you greg on the
other side of it
with all due respect to president biden
you have not ended the war you've
extended it
you have made it bigger not smaller
you're going to do
to us what you did in iraq put us in a
world of hurt
this is repeating obama in iraq all over
again
okay greg well um i don't know
uh first to those who said that this uh
could cause another 911 uh did they
predict the last one
because if they predicted the last one
that i'll listen to them i
i agree with dana that um
basing a decision predicating the
decision on a symbolic date
is idiotic it's absolutely idiotic it
just it just says
i mean if you're telling me yeah we have
you know what yep it took us one day
to to take 20 years of your existence
i think it's a i think we won there i
also love how the pro-war
uh factions in the media turning this
into a betrayal of feminism
that if you're leaving afghanistan
somehow you don't like the women there
i've seen that a couple of times but and
also to dana's point
leaving a country now is not like
leaving a country 10 or 15 years ago
in today's world of technology and
drones drone warfare
artificial intelligence nobody ever
leaves completely
something happens we'll be back or we'll
be there in some
manner or form i mean it's kind of like
one of those retractable awnings that we
sell on this network
you know if you need to go if you need
to open us up we'll be there
but in the meantime we're going to pull
back
all right jesse what what do you say to
the fact that they're really only 2500
americans there
and pompeo said today that you know no
americans have been killed since
whatever agreement was that they
that they made with the taliban uh that
we've got like
50 000 and 20 000 in spain and
other countries around the world does it
matter what the number is
it will just because you take the 2500
out and as dana
said you're going to leave special
operators and you're going to leave cia
task forces in
to be the eyes and ears on the ground
and then report back
to langley they're reconstituting this
is what they're doing
but you got to give these guys a little
air cover i understand you might want to
keep some
air supported bagram keep that open but
right now bagram
the air base is probably the least
safe us military asset in the entire
world it just got a little less safe
so you're going to have some contractors
there defending
all that infrastructure i feel like
they'll pull out a bagram
just in a few years but it's a mess
afghanistan it's landlocked
surrounded by iran pakistan russia you
like that neighborhood
it's a logistical nightmare just to have
a presence there to begin with
and we've already spilled a lot of blood
a lot of treasure
as biden said we nailed bin laden you
can't
keep propping up a central government
they've never had central governments
that work there
it's tribal warlords it's provincial
powers
and these corrupt military guys were
training
they turn their backs on you they steal
they don't fight well
it's very tough to get these guys up and
ready so and
i hate that's no there's no good options
and that's sad
but like dana said you can leave
honorably and we should be proud of what
we accomplished
all right harold in the last 30 seconds
uh
mcconnell said it's a grave mistake
we're retreated
uh and in the in the enemies uh
uh in their opinion we have pretty much
retreated and they won
i i don't i don't agree with uh leader
mcconnell i traveled to afghanistan iraq
israel with senator senator graham
the late senator mccain and senator then
senator now president biden
i think if they're you think about the
three or four more most serious thinkers
about this region of the world in the
last 15
20 years those four those three would be
right near the top of the five or six
i think it's important to take a step
back and look at what we've accomplished
i think dana laid it out very well
i think four presidents now this this
war has covered we've laid all the facts
out
but it may be time to reset and
recalibrate our foreign policy national
security interests
you think about where we're spending you
think about where we're going to have to
spend and re-pivot or should say pivot
towards asia particularly china
is this the right time to do it are they
going to take i think september 11th
setting that date i would agree with
jesse was not
necessarily or correct not necessarily
the smartest thing however
i do think they will this president who
is not new to foreign policy who is not
new to this issue who has been daring in
the past about offering solutions
i think will will be consistent with
that i was good i was happy to see
senator graham in one regard i think he
was a little fired up perhaps a little
too much
but i love it when he gets that way
because when he lays out ideas
biden loves that kind of back and forth
hopefully they'll find a
the right medium and the right
compromise on when the troops should
lead because i think that
eventually is where we're going to end
up well he already said it
all right